nasa's view from the international space
station shows just how big harvey is
forecasters say houston america's fourth
largest city could get at least 20
inches of rain it is the home of a
multi-billion dollar oil and gas
industry manuel bojorquez is in port
lavaca texas with the potential risk to
those facilities manuel good morning
good morning as we start to feel the
first effects of hurricane harvey the
rain the wind and the rising tide the
comparisons to 2008's hurricane ike have
already begun but scientists say if
hurricane harvey remains on its current
path it could be far more destructive
with harvey's arrival now imminent
people are moving inland away from the
low-lying coastal areas that were nearly
obliterated by hurricane ike in 2008
walls blown out boats turned upside down
some cars floating hurricane ike holds
the distinction of being the costliest
weather event in texas history 103
people were killed in the u.s while
about 30 billion dollars was spent to
repair the damage the galveston seawall
is 17 feet high a storm surge over that
could travel from the gulf of mexico
into galveston bay and up the houston
shipping channel crippling one of the
nation's busiest ports it's also home to
several major refineries hopefully this
is a wake-up call but it could become a
absolute horror movie jim blackburn is
an environmental engineer at rice
university he says houston's current
infrastructure won't hold up if the city
takes a hit if we reach those levels
we could see the worst environmental
disaster in united states history and
would probably shut down and
cause a major gap in gasoline and jet
fuel and other types of critical
products availability for some texans
that's reason enough to leave town we
don't know what's going to happen we
don't know if we're going to come back
to home or what damage we're coming home
to and so it's kind of it's sad it's
scary
and with hurricane harvey on course to
hit the region's cluster of oil
refineries which output more than 5
million barrels of oil per day
nationwide the average price of gas is
already surged to levels not seen since
april
bill manuel with the effects of the
storm down there